elizabeth warren elizabeth warren you
know this is the fake native american
okay
this is a woman who pretended pretended
that she was a native american to get a
job as a professor
while she calls everybody else racist i
mean that's pretty much the most racist
thing you could possibly do
because not only are you getting a job
that you really don't deserve if you
believe in that identity politics stuff
you're actually stopping a native
american person from
getting that very job that you took
white lady
well she is coming out swinging
for gavin newsom and listen to her ad
that she's putting out
for old gavin and yeah she's a democrat
she's a progressive
so it's full of lies here's the deal
with the recall of gavin newsom
we've seen trump republicans across the
country
attacking election results and the right
to vote
now they're coming to grab power in
california
abusing the recall process and costing
taxpayers millions here's how we stop
them
every californian will get a mail-in
ballot for the september 14th election
vote no to protect california and our
democracy
stop the republican recall
awful they're just nauseating i need to
start taking imodium before the show i
think maybe that would be a good idea
these people are just
absolutely horrible first off it's the
trump republicans of course
that are causing the recall this is very
much in line with what bernie
has been saying in aoc and the rest of
them these are evil right-wingers the
implication is of course these are
racist
people somehow uh even though gavin
newsom's white and the guy who that
is going to replace him is black but
putting that aside for a moment that
they're all evil and they're it's
republicans doing this i just want to
say this again i've been to so many of
the rallies about opening up this state
the people that are at the rallies it's
not even that they're not republicans
they're not even
they're not democrats they're not
political people for the most part
they're just
regular people restaurateurs small
business people
everyone hates gavin that should be the
name of the sitcom
you've got to go i don't care where you
go but you can't stay here
so of course she lies that these are
trump republicans calling
for the recall so she's saying basically
that 1.7 million trump republicans in
california
signed that recall thing to make it
happen okay so that's just a lie
she says of course that they're
attacking elections which this is
completely
congruent with everything else that
these ridiculous people are saying
attacking elections yes
we're attacking elections by using the
electoral process by using
the constitutional process of recalling
these people we have
these systems put into place so that
when we have really horrific
authoritarian
governors we can get rid of them by the
way it's not in the
uh too distant future that california
did this california before i lived here
had a recall of gray davis and remember
arnold schwarzenegger i'll be back it's
not otuma
he became the governor okay so these
things have happened in the past was it
trump republicans
that was pre-trump but trump's like a
time machine for these people anything
can happen with trump
um so attacking elections i mean look
again you guys know
all this stuff the all of these election
bills georgia
texas everywhere that they're doing
these election bills it's about voter id
it's about paper trails it's about video
cameras when people are accounting
it's to secure elections it is these
clownish
buffoons who are trying to destroy the
election process
uh she also says they're abusing the
recall process well no they're just not
i think i illustrated that
already and also just is there anyone
more inauthentic
than than elizabeth warren remember i'm
going to get me a beer
and then she walks off camera on that
little live stream and that will never
cease to amaze me like really
i think sociologists and psychologists
probably anthropologists years from now
should all
study how a billionaire
orange man from new york was more
authentic than every single one of the
people who hated him
it's just absolutely incredible
absolutely incredible